só isso já conhece ou já ninguém vai
acontecer um monte de coisas
ae eu vou trocar com ele agora fala no
evento
o latitude pessoal daqui quem fala é o
dar que seja muito em mim jamais um
vídeo e o estrago de que faz nas sete
freires dois estamos aqui para jogar
então à noite cinco nós temos quase no
final do jogo e cada vez está mais
complicado cada vez está mais difícil
que só por isso deixem desde já o vosso
enorme e grande apoio ontem foi tudo
agora pessoas serem muito obrigado por
tudo o que vocês têm dado nesta série e
vamos lá então seguir com a noite cinco
pessoal à noite quatro eu acabei por
estar há pouco por isso não viram 84
passem por lá o link está na descrição é
o link esta noite eo link da noite todas
por isso passei por lá pessoal vejam
este google não começarmos pessoal ou
cai a noite cinco não quero saber ele
não quer saber de chamada eu vou passar
isso tudo sem ajudas não quer saber o
que o pessoal do meia noite é as coisas
vão começar a complicar a partir de
agora é meia noite mas muitas companhias
já estava quase a acabar meu ea gastar
muito rápido o que aí já aconteceu uma
coisa que conta é o que aí é só raposa
mark s pulse raposa que aparece o início
é calma rolou lá palhaço para gastar
muito rápido agora vou ter muito cuidado
com este palhaço agora cá está tranquilo
está tranqüilo ou o google andrew z do
balão do balão não dizer olá meu país
nunca tinha acontecido isso nunca tinha
acontecido calma calma e tentar ataques
quanto ao calendário isso
eu fui embora agora exatamente sou muito
fácil sem dar pistas para julgar este
fait fredes estou lendo os comentários
que só dos vossos comentários
mas é o que acontece é que com a opção
do jogo não conseguiu ver como estava a
dizer é é uma voz que é isto
calma eu explico o trabalho publicado
deixe me deixem ver o que isto é
eu estou é pinto estou no meio da festa
sim e tem que fazer o que tem pra
ninguém né
até este mini jogos são muito bizarros
pessoa louca eu vou seguir aquele gastar
lá em cima
lá o gado ou o o preço vai dizer letras
ou alguma coisa assim parece estar
solteira letras
ok pessoal isto vai dar susto já tiradas
fontes a par do assunto aqui em botafogo
5º andar às voltas meu sangue sangue no
chão sem o chão eu tava com dor da morte
não estão a aprender
eu acho que o afastaram conseguir melhor
do que um pc
ok pessoal ok não condicionada desta vez
mas como eu estava explicar pessoal eu
tenho lido os vossos comentários tenham
ouvido as vossas ajudas mas o que
acontece eu o vi jogar aqui está atenta
opção que muitas vezes não consigo fazer
que o vosso jejum dizem ajuda com vocês
não dão tempo experiência pessoal mas
vamos lá então é tentar passar esta
noite cinco é meia noite ainda o tempo
está a passar muito foi agora meu né o
zé do palhaço não baixei dentro não
porque não queira noite ainda estava
muito lento
isto é muito lenta passar agora não
pagasse não baixei escreve que eu te
digo que não vai chegar nunca mais
palhaço
ok ok ok o zé do bombom está aqui dentro
eu saí dali lembro
calma calma agora que está tudo bem
agora está tudo bem com ela aqui dentro
eu sei o que eu queria na boca e zach
zatz até do balão ou ou gols quando têm
os raposas
calma isso observando aqui está tudo
tranquilo aqui ainda que o serra há
pouca gente em cima já está tranquilo eu
disse vou lá e eu aqui né
está aqui o que esconder embora o que
acho que vou embora exatamente
exatamente agora já se enganaram cdu
manuel da uma da manhã pessoal uma da
manhã
só que aí o carioca aí calma calma seco
é digo-o calma e mais longa noite a
turma senhora tem calma contigo
não dá pra seguir ainda meu não dá pra
se ninguém o palhaço em calma isso calma
calma
pelo andar outra vez josé do balão
caraças a capital está a ficar muito
difícil muito difícil mesmo eu já nem
sei o que eu vou falar meu calma calma
zé do palhaço
ok ok ok ok
ou ela aqui não está tranquilo tranquilo
andre agassi de pagar só que o palhaço
como este tudo meu
o palhaço com o instituto a faca
amanhã o estômago está bem
aguenta banho tomar conta do futebol lá
estar descontente e aí exatamente uma
semana
vamos atacar enganei me enganei ninguém
menina não vai matar ninguém e nem me
wind nani vai matar da champions
há pois pensava com isso engajamento mas
no nosso espaço que eu fui embora a
tempo
ok ou estão mini jogo novo jet fred ok
só conseguiu afastar o pessoal porque o
meu é que é um caminho grande então se
eu tiver aqui perto disto não consigo
ler
ok go go que está acontecer
o botafogo é que quando acontecerá o
show foxy ela na fox galgam não entender
o pessoal não entender o que está
acontecendo
o botafogo agora tenho um anel para mim
leo gão eu estou aí não sei se sabes o
que é história diferente
já estava à espera
perto então é o gol o peixe marcou a
pagar freire pós pós greve está com
apenas 35 acham que alguém é que alguém
não fazem com a população vai ter uma
frase eu sou teu amigo eu tenho uma
cabeça igualar a tua alma do inferno
executá la em tamanho quanto levar a
corda
calma calma calma calma calma não sei lá
o que caraças
a mapfre calma pedaço calma palhaço que
nenê o que só é muito difícil está muito
difícil
está muito difícil está muito difícil
está muito difícil também difícil nunca
se dizer explicitamente muito difícil
talvez muito difícil talvez muito
difícil fugir da manhã às 11 da manhã já
aconteceu muitas coisas
ae outro caso com até agora falando num
evento são sim tamanha caraças são cinco
da manhã pessoal são cinco da manhã meu
sim também a pessoal sem da manhã
são cinco da manhã são cinco da manhã
quinta noite
são cinco da manhã o maior enfoque em
god
se conseguir passar isso a sério carga
de cinta manhã às cinco da manhã
sinto me melhor falar que tu consegues
falar eu vou fingir que é uma da manhã
conseguiu encostar em curso que passaram
a quinta noite só ser vocês não têm
noção vocês não têm noção com quem não
conseguir falar ou cápsula onu chega
mesmo
vocês não tem noção de quanto tempo
fiquei a equipe falando sério eu fiquei
que muito tempo não tanto quanto
fascinante é fredes 1 mas foi mesmo
muito tempo fala sério um cheque sem
dólares 50 centro
não é nada mal é ok eu tenho já uma
estrela e à noite seis cápsulas sério é
porém mesmo fortemente o esférico voz
like favorito eu fiquei muito tempo só
pois vocês vão ver num best mohmand sou
assim
short de desespero pessoal do puro
desespero meu mas eis quando o vosso
apoio o aik favorito fiquem bahia até a
próxima
olha
[Música]